Какая разница а потім навіть сказав що
без світла без газу але без вас класно
чого так взяло маском Я не знаю Ну на
жаль мені здається що розуміння
важливості культури принаймні в
керівникам Міністерства відсутні факапи
інформаційна політика чи це добре чи це
норма це інші питання це норм
зараз розглядається в Раді вже майже
прийнято Наскільки я розумію
законопроект Про
деінтереалізацію і ключове питання в
чому ви один з фактично організаторів
декомунізації і зараз оце продовження
політики Наскільки я розумію вже день
перелізації в чому різниця Що це таке
трошки зразу поправлю деінтералізація це
цей процес який я сподіваюся колись
почнеться в Росії і Росія буде
позбуватися своєї імперської спадщини
Україна не була імперія Україна була
колонія тому у нас процес який стартує
вже як державна політика після ухвалення
два дні тому відповідно закону він вже
ухвалено чекаємо тепер тільки на
підписання президента це про це все-таки
деколонізація Тобто ми позбавляємся від
колоніальної спадщини причому
колоніальної спадщини якраз тієї імперії
яка зараз
чинить потуги відновити своїм імперську
спадщину відновитися єперський вплив на
Україні тому там надзвичайно важливо так
само як з декомунізацію позбавлятися
всіх цих маркерів Русского Мира на
українській території які можуть і
використовувалися і ще будуть
використовувати
для того щоб говорити що ми один народ
для того щоб виправдовувати російську
агресію проти України Я з самого початку
коли ми тільки започаткували
декомунізацію казав що наступним етапи
має бути деколонізація Ну трошки
побачите в нас Була пауза яка очевидно
було спричинена політичними подіями
після зміни влади в 2019 році добре що
вже тепер врешті дозріли і відповідно
закон ухвалено Я дуже сподіваюсь що
Президент його підпише і оці ініціативи
які свідками яких ми є з перейменування
населених пунктів які пов'язані з
історією російською імперії з
перейменуванням вулиць демонтажу
пам'ятник все це врешті решта е-е буде
тепер здійснюватися як державна політика
дуже добре що є громадські інспективи я
дуже сподіваю що вони не зникнуть але
надзвичайно важливо щоб цей процес мав
певні законодавчі легітимні рамки тепер
він буде їх мати і відповідний механізм
який долучить до цієї роботи вже органи
державної влади знову таки Аналогічно як
із декомунізацією процес розглядати ми
таким чином що перші півроку на
реалізацію цих завдань буде мати буде
мати місцеві Ради після того якщо ними
не буде е-е реалізовано положення цього
закону тоді повноваження приходять до
голів міських рад якщо тут знову таки
зустрінемося саботажем тоді вже очевидно
все буде вирішуватися по виконавчих
вертикалі головними адміністрації з
декомунізацію це спрацювало на відсотків
90 з лишком от я думаю так само спрацює
з декогонізацією проде колонізація
можете от на конкретних прикладах для
тих хто не знає не розуміє що це ну що
це означає от вели цей закон що далі це
означає що населення пункти назви яких
прив'язані до
Російської історії в формі існування
Росії в протягом історії в будь-яких
формах тобто від Московського царства до
Російської Федерації умовні населені
пункти які називаються в честь якихось
там полководців в діячів Росії
потьомкіни воронцової і так далі мають
бути перейменовані так само це
стосується якихось пам'ятних знаків яких
досить багато в Україні які знову-таки є
маркерами якраз е-е які ставили
Російська імперія на нашій території для
того щоб потім сказати що це територія
завжди була наша тобто тут аналогія з
декомунізацією досить близька і я
сподіваюсь що так само ця аналогія
спрацює і найглибшому рівні що ми не
просто будемо позбавлятися цих якихось
зовнішніх Марків що теж важливо але що
ця процес позбавлення тих зовнішніх
маркерів спровокує серйозно і дискусію в
суспільстві Що ж його саме мали би
позбавлятися в контексті декомунізація
так як було це з декомунізацією Ну щоб
було ще зрозуміліше видно що мова йде і
про не тільки про якихось
військово-політичних діячів мова йде і
про події такі як до прикладу увічнення
так званої російської слави Полтавська
битва і всі меморіали які їм присвячують
місто прекрасне українське місто яке
просто засмічений засмічене просто тими
усіма російськими маркерами мова йде про
тих діячів навіть культури російською
які по суті виправдовували і займалися
пропагандою Російської імперії ну в
першу чергу Очевидно це які трубадури
імперії як лев толстої і Олександр
Пушкін обидва не просто є якимось там
письменниками поетами не будуть
сперечатися про їхні заслуги власним в
художньому слові але обидва були тими
хто створювали власне ці російські
імперські міфи створювали ідеологічне
Підріжжя для Російської імперії яке досі
використовується Росія для виправдання
своїх якихось зазіханьєй сучасної
російської агресії зокрема проти України
якщо плавно Ну не плавно не зовсім
плавним ми різко перейдемо до
інформаційної політики нашої країни
от найперше в мене питання виникає таке
що не так за новим маску щоб так взяло
мазком Я не знаю він людина дуже
специфічна дуже буду дуже непослідовна
от я думаю що треба зрозуміти що є певні
риси ілона-маска які дуже добрі які
треба його треба використовувати на
благо і користь України і не встидатись
це це робити от Хай живе тарлінка разом
з цим зрозуміти що ця людина дуже не
цілісна дуже клаптикова і якісь його
дурнювати заяви Ну слава Богу вони не
мають якогось вирішального впливу на
якісь політичні рішення ти ж Сполучених
Штатах Америки чи якихось інших країнах
тому е-е з цим можна змиритися Цим можна
терпіти якщо користь є від його
конкретних кроків які ми можемо
викликати якихось винаків таких установ
таких як старовин які ми можемо
використовувати Мені здається що це
проблема власне я ще особистісна в пана
маска людина яка Ну до певної міри в
якихось своїх технічних питаннях є
геніальною здатні такі геніальних
винаходів Але разом з тим психологічно
очевидно потребує збурювати довкола себе
чергові хвилі хейтер от він він він це
любить а чи не вважаєте ви що це реально
кейс типу про валу інформаційної
політики України та це не
інформаційної політики в Україні і мені
здається що
такі провали які
цілком би залежали від України тому що
Вплинути якось на Ілона маска Ну навряд
чи можливо тобто якщо Хтось думає що він
передасть ілону маску книжку з історії
України він її прочитає законспектує От
і зміни собі погляди на минулу Ну так не
буває от е-е я думаю що набагато
серйозніші Якщо говорити про якісь
факапи інформаційної політики То вони в
першу чергу внутрішній інформаційна
політики ну по-перше
найбільшим факапом інформаційної
політики є звичайно марафон єдиний
новини Тобто це інформаційний продукт
який вже не просто перестиг який вже
просто Ну протухлявів напевно От такі
абсолютно вже не виконує жодної
позитивної ролі а тільки негативну роль
хоча Ну треба розуміти що
наші знаєте можливо оцінки що влада не
розуміє цього тому так по інерції
зберіга
вони вони наївні Влада Прекрасна це
розуміє єдиний марафон виконує одну
важливу функцію в шкідливу в цілому для
розвитку держави Я вважаю він призводить
до того що люди які цікавилися
суспільно-політичним життям в державі
перестають цікавитися
включаєшся і ящик а там тобі
розповідають про успіхи в стилі в
збільшенні молока от який Звичайно що це
нікому не цікаво От і ця не цікавість Ну
вона призводить до того що суспільство
поступово байдужі до тих процесів які
відбуваються в країні ті хто
небайдужіють роблять другий крок Який
теж Ну в принципі в цілому стратегічного
небезпечній неправильні Вони шукають
якісь інші джерела інформації і На жаль
багато її знаходять в
анонімних джерелах якими просто
наповнений телеграм для мене для
історика телеграм - це зло тому що він в
принципі
задуманий плекає можливість анонімних
джерел інформації для історика робота з
джерелами це означає в першу чергу
розуміння хто створив це джерело який
він мав доступ до інформації який в
нього наміри в поширені цієї інформації
телеграм здебільшого не дає такої
можливості От і дуже прикро знаєте що
люди е-е не маючи жодної інформації про
те що сталося Тут буквально щось
прилетіло десь бахнуло його треба
зрозуміти навіть міркувань безпеки що що
сталося замість того щоб отримати якусь
оперативну і правильну інформацію
очевиднованої інформації зважаючи на те
що війну Але тим не менше отримати буде
якусь інформацію від якогось
перевіреного джерела інформації шукають
якісь Вибачте умовні труси от е-е
вважаючи що там вони знайдуть правильну
інформацію часом Так Але часом серед
цієї правління інформації яка подається
анонімне джерелом з'являється Якийсь
дуже дивні інформації брехливі
інформації відверті маніпуляції і оце
прикормлювання людей до
телеграм-каналів Ну воно зло тому що
люди не не навчені якоїсь інформаційної
гігієни дуже легко стають жертвами
інформацій і це другий крок який до кого
призводить власне оці всі факапи з
внутрішньою комунікаціями в
інформаційній політиці в Україні і на
жаль це це знову таки теж треба ще ж
крім цього іншого треба розуміти що оця
от відсутність якоїсь інформаційної
гігієни вміння працювати з джерелами яка
їхала для більшості українців Вони теж
на користь в Росії для Росії телеграм
прекрасний насправді засіб донесення
різного роду провокаційно будь-якої
інформації яка буде розхитувати
суспільство от якщо Хтось думає що Росія
Ну буде обов'язково в Україні ставити на
якусь політичну силу якогось там
політичного лідера для того щоб зробити
собі в Україні чергову російську
політика Медведчук ні Цього вже напевно
не буде тому що Росія розуміє що
можливості для цього вже мізерні в
Україні але Росія буде ставити на те щоб
посилювати взаємно ненависть між
українцями які представ багато різних
там прихильникам різних політичних сил
тобто оцей хейд взаємний який множиться
соціальними мережами він прекрасно
виконує ті цілі які стоять перед Росією
в в судячих якраз полягає в тому щоб
потроху розхитувати українське
суспільство з середини яке насправді є
консолідовано а це можливо знову-таки є
завдяки тому що на жаль українців
відлучають від якихось
нормальну від споживання нормальної
перевіреної інформації дуже-дуже
неправильно дуже неприємним знову таки
ще один інформаційним факапом є
повернення до політики створення
державної інформаційних каналів Тобто це
90-ті роки які На жаль хочуть повернути
в нашу реальність е всі ці доми Freedom
ми зараз кажуть що буде телеканалу
Міністерства оборони не знаю гармата чи
як він там буде називатися інформаційна
от але це абсурд насправді Тобто це е-е
відводить нас знову-таки в бік від того
на що ми всі орієнтуємося європейською
інтеграції це неприпустимо з точки зору
європейської інтеграції але це класно
для засвоєння двох мільярдів гривень
бюджету в той час коли кажуть що нам
бракує грошей на все на дому фрідами на
телеканал Рада який Напевно скоро почне
забувати як виглядає приміщення
парламенту от На Це теж гроші є тому що
жодних жодної якоїсь інформації про
здійснення діяльності в парламенті Цей
канал так само не готові не готові
подавати тому мені здається що
загалом інформаційна політика в Україні
внутрішня вона дуже слабка вона не
спрямована на те щоб якось інтегрувати
суспільство посилювати суспільство вона
заточена на якісь посилення симпатії до
вчинної очевидної влади можна зрозуміти
Але мені здається що е-е коли це
робиться аж аж на Шкоду суспільство То
тут то це напевно не неприпустимо
безперечно що головним оператором такої
інформаційної політики є Міністерство
культури інформаційної політики от яке
ну
в Широкому сенсі обласної культури
інформаційно-політики комуністиці коли
Та не справляється з цими завданнями
яких постали перед ними в обличчі цієї
війни ми поговорили про поразки А в мене
питання чиєї все ж таки якийсь Перемоги
якщо є точії це заслуги ну найбільша
перемога і це заслуга очевидно
українського народу це те що ми сьогодні
з вами розглядаємо в Києві от а не десь
за кордоном згадуючи про те як добре
було коли було незалежна Україна тобто
це величезна перемога і в цьому заслуга
саме українців які стали на захист своєї
держави в цьому заслуга Кияни які
ставимо захист Києва в цьому заслугу
кожного хто якимось своїми зусиллями
зробили так що російський бліцкриг
провалився Минулого року я думаю що є
величезні заслуги інформаційної
дипломатичної можливо сказати
політики е-е яка суть якої полягає в
тому що нам вдалося показати що
сьогоднішня російська українська війна
це не просто російсько-українська війна
це не просто якийсь територіальні
претензії до України з боку Росії це
війна між вільним світом західної
цивілізації і цивілізацією
якогось рабства цивілізації
е-е такої найгіршої Азії орди яку
представляє між собою Росія тут очевидно
що величезне заслуга наших дипломатів і
тут попри моя критичне ставлення до
президента Зеленського як президента
який виконує не найкращим Мені здається
свої функції як
внутрішньополітичні функції так він
прекрасно виконує їх на зовнішньому
політичному грунті він прекрасно
представляє країну як воюють Україну яка
здатна боротися і очевидно що
капіталізує якось свої ці акторські
здібності на те щоб
тримати досить високий ступінь підтримки
України Я дивився інтерв'ю Ткаченка з
яніною Ну в мене немає інших слів щоб
описати Це це в мене є одне слово яке є
в когось запозичив я його не вигадав але
воно дуже чітко описує те що я почув
побачив качечная
питання полягає в тому так А чим
займається взагалі міністерство
інформаційної політики культури і сам
міністр Ткаченко На жаль мені здається
що розуміння важливості культури саме
тепер саме в час війни війни за
ідентичність в принаймні в керівникам
Міністерства відсутні тому коли знаєте
Ми чуємо дискусії в нас на комітеті з
питань інформаційної гуманітарної
політики які пов'язані з бюджетом з
фінансування тих чи інших якихось
інституцій культурних і бачимо позицію
міністра який вважає за нормальним що
Денег нет новодержитесь от ну це
абсолютно неприпустимо він абсолютно
щиро переконаний що війна виправдовує
неувагу держави до культури замість того
щоб навпаки бути одним з тих хто
нагадував в керівництво держави що так
війна це звичайно оборона це звичайно
армія але культура - це теж оборона це
наш другий оборонний вал після збройних
сил України і він теж потребу ресурсу і
уваги він цього не робить Він більш того
ще раз кажу користається тим що ну є
війна грошей нема які які до нас
претензії В нас немає можливості ні ні
ні нічого фінансувати Це абсолютно
неправильно її не пропустимо Тоді в мене
відразу питання до каналів які Ми
займаємося е-е наші міністерством
інформаційної політики Ну толомарафон ми
не беремо е-е от Мені цікаво почути
думку про Freedom оці канали які там
Freedom цей розважальний зробили потім є
freedom-новинний дом є дом короче який
вже перестав бути російськомовним який
став україномовним але від того він не
став якимось україномосичем тому що Ну
насправді Пункт перший я взагалі не
розумію доцільності існування цих
каналів тому що це державне телебачення
яке неприпустимо це державне телебачення
яке займається якоюсь е Квазі пропаганди
тому що це навіть це це навіть не
Пропаганда це здебільшого очевидно що
мова йде про просто засвоєння якихось
бюджетних коштів інших якихось сенсів
існування для цих
інформаційних інструментів Я не бачу І
знаєте коли ми слухали слухавались звіт
телеканалу Freedom які нам розказував
про те що вони мало не формують
інформаційний порядок денний в
Російській Федерації
впливають колосальну настрій в
російському суспільстві ну це був щедрий
і по-інакшому цього не назвеш коли воно
називають якісь дуже дивні цифри
переглядів в Ютубі і вважають що це
інструмент інформаційної політики Який
Ось розвалить е-е російської імперію це
дуже і дуже і дуже несерйозно насправді
тому я не бачу доцільності я не бачив
виправдання для існування цих
інструментів Я переконаний що ті Кошти
які використовуються на існування цих як
мінімум цих двох каналів можна знайти
набагато ефективніше їх використання
навіть в рамках того самого міністерства
культури інформаційної політики в нас до
прикладу є такий е-е інституція важливо
як Український інститут який має
займатися культурною дипломатією йому
систематично не додають коштів на його
діяльність тим не менше навіть в такому
обмеженому фінансуванням він час від
часу проявляється в дуже цікавому
інвестиціями достатньо це ну в кінці
Минулого року цей Концерт щедрика холл -
Це круто Це От ця приклад того як має
працювати держава коли ми говорили
успіхи ми говоримо забув про це але це
от приклад прекрасний культурних
дипломатії тому але очевидно що Він
потребує ресурси очевидно що Він
потребує грошей є Які зараз витрачаються
на щось зовсім інше А можете конкретніше
про який успіх саме Ну от для про
концерти який відбувся в Карнегі Холл
нью-йорк до річниці е-е
виступу капели Кошиця Яка ще в 1919 році
почали їздити по світу потім в виступила
в Сполучені Штатах Америки якраз в
карники холе в нью-йорку відбувся
концерт на якому вперше тоді прозвучав
тверджень всесвітньо відомий Щедрик тоді
він ще був абсолютно свіжим твором який
потім поступово трансформувався в Карлов
the Bells так от Минулого року в тому
самому залі за участю українських
виконавців хорів відбулося презентація
концерту з
того самого щедрика Тобто це прекрасно
просто виглядало пряма трансляція е-е
американський ведучий Тобто Ну от
приклад того як можна як треба робити ще
один варіант власне на що могли би піти
до фінансування замість фінансування
якихось незрозумілих проектів типу дому
і Freedom Це очевидно суспільне Тобто це
той канал який е-е знову-таки є ознакою
нормального демократичного суспільства
який тільки починав спинатися на ноги і
зараз він отримав єдиний удар з одного
боку це хронічний недофінансування хоча
ще раз Хочу сказати що є в принципі
деякі додаткові ресурс дати для цього
каналу от а з другого боку включення
його в єдиний марафон Ну мені здається
що йде йому суттєво на Шкоду тому що на
жаль єдиний марафон дуже за політично
заточений під партію влади і очевидно що
е-е спроба суспільного зберігати
політично нейтральність яка була в
принципі успішна абсолютно до 2000 е
2022 року Вона зараз трошки розмивається
тому що навіть якщо всередині самого
соту суспільного ця нейтральне
зберігається Тобто вона періодична так
само включають як представника
опозиційної партії то в цілому якщо
подивитися е-е весь цей марафон тут це
зрозуміло що це працює на малину однієї
політичної сили і на жаль кидає тінь на
в суспільне але я з оптимізмом ставлюся
до можливостей розвитку подальшого
суспільного Мені дуже подобається якийсь
їхній такі
історично-просвітницькі продукти знову
таки я вже сьогодні згадував Щедрик
прекрасний фільм про Щедрик от
документальний фільм в є дуже класний ще
фільм кілька років тому був в тому
зроблений колапс Тобто це знову дивіться
такі продукти які е-е є таке манекенками
для того щоб потім їх використовувати
тут в Україні і їх точно можна виносити
на зоні для того щоб показувати хто ми
чому ми не Росія А чому чому ми інші І
що Щедрик якщо колапс абсолютно
дорогаяся Україна після нашої перемоги А
ми всі знаємо що перемога ця буде рано
чи пізно ну краще раніше ніж пізніше але
вона буде країною яка захистила свободу
та демократію ми вже відомі на весь світ
і будемо відомі на весь світ цим самим
як на вашу думку має діяти наша
інформаційна політика далі щоб ну
наприклад стати ті ж британією ну не
дати про себе забути насправді тобто так
зараз ціною страшної
біди крові ми на передових
інформаційного фронту про нас знають про
нас пам'ятають але треба розуміти що
завершення безпосередніх бойових дій
призведе до того що в речейство України
поступово можуть забувати Тому ми маємо
про себе нагадувати ми маємо ну
показувати чим ми є унікальні чим мене
цікавить для світу от Здатність чинити
спротив здатність протистояти Здавалося
б значно сильніші армії і зупиняти її це
це цікаво якщо ми на це На на цю
цікавість лише навісимо додаткові якісь
цікавинки для світу покажемо якісь
особливості нашого культурного розвитку
якоїсь особливо нашої літератури музика
і так далі то ми зможемо закріпити за
собою якісь оцей Імідж унікальної країни
цього регіону зараз для нас унікальний
шанс вийти з тієї Росії ми сотні років
були в тіні от російська ця густа Чорна
тінь призвела до того що навіть якщо
щось знали е-е про Україну якісь там
яскраві зразки української культури і
умовно якось Серж лифар як зірка балету
все одно це асоціація з Росією А це
Росія тобто все Що все Що добре
українське сприймалося як російське
зараз є можливість розірвати оцю от
пуповину вийти вийти ще раз хочу сказати
з цієї російської тіні і треба робити це
активно треба робити це активно треба
очевидно щоб е-е тут держава не не
боялася використовувати якийсь ресурс
просувати свою культуру у світі Я дуже
тішуся що зараз багато українських
видавництв вийшли поза межі України де з
моїх улюблених 11 Старого Лева визнано
одним з кращих видавництв дитячої
літератури в Європі Тобто це це шанс
не просто раз спалахнути і зникнути
забутими але застовбити за собою якесь
цікаве унікальне місце в європейській
культурі Саме через культуру ми маємо
закріпитися другий аспект тобто бачите
тут постійно в нас поєднання в розмові
між культурою і оборонця звичайно
оборона ми
за результатами цієї війни після
перемоги у цій війні
будемо мати одну з найуспішніших
найкращих армій яка матиме просто
унікальний досвід жодна інша армія світу
нема тебе такого досвіду коли мають
українці і цей досить очевидно треба
буде зафіксувати цей досить це буде те
що ми ті знання які ми зможемо
експортувати нашим союзникам Я думаю що
зважаючи на те що зараз відбувається нам
надзвичайно важливо перебудувати якісь
свої військово-промисловий комплекс для
того щоб пристосувати його до новітніх
умов знову-таки це дуже Дорогою ціною
куплений шанс який ми мусимо повністю
скористатися і Україна Ну може собі
знати знаєте в світовій геополітиці
такий
таке місце форпосту басейну Свободи за
яким Так на жаль швидше за все
починається якийсь територія не Свободи
от але ми маємо розуміти що власне з
нашого форпосту стримавши цю поширення
на Свободи дальше на захід ми маємо бути
готовими поширювати нашу свободу дальше
на Схід і очевидно що шукати союзників
підтримувати союзників на території
самої Російської Федерації Ні це не
хороший русский і це не друга і Росія це
має бути якраз представники цих
по-новому народі Росії які очевидно
потребують підтримки для того щоб
нагадати цілому освітою про їхнє право
на національне самовизначення між іншим
я хотів запитати якраз про
інформаційну політику згадав питання
в Росії типу ми ж туди щось працюємо
крім Freedom на скільки взагалі
ефективно ми туди працюємо
на жаль тобто Хочеться вірити знаєте що
в нас є якісь там підпільні канали якими
ми поступово розхитуємо російську
федерацію якими ми маємо якісь канали
комунікації з тими ж представниками
панового народу в Росії
Ну на жаль я такого не бачу фактично в
систему можливо Добре що не бачимо
можливо це справді що секретно тобто
прекрасно розумієш що частина цієї
інформації і повинна такою бути але ну
нічого би не завадило і говорити про
якусь системну інформаційну політику в
цілому тому До речі от всі ці доми
Freedom ще чим побували от вони якраз
знову таки були готові говорити про
хороших рухів вони були готові Шукати
тих Хороших і вони періодично включали в
ефірі якісь непонятних Аля лібералів з
Російської Федерації замість того щоб
все-таки шукати союзників все-таки серед
тих кого я називає по-новому народами
Росії Це інший зовсім тактика стратегія
відповідно в інші інструменти мали би
підбиратися для такої роботи кажуть що
Арестович став єдиним джерелом
заспокоєння українського народу
протягом там двох перших тижнів точно
2-3 перших тижнів
чи це є так Ні ну він виконав свою
позитивну роль коли справді була
наростала паніка очевидно що треба було
трохи якогось заспокійливого
знеболювального Але коли
заспокійливалось знеболю вона дуже
багато то можна просто не Прокинутися От
і дуже багато людей
під
заколисування його баритончика на жаль
почали просто засинати впадати в якийсь
летаргічний сон Багато людей не хочу
прокидатися тому що реальність набагато
жорсткіше ніж те що розповідає росовища
Ну і слухати росовичок про те що ми вже
завтра будемо в криву звичайно приємніше
ніж слухати якогось військовика який
розповідає про те як важко зараз
підбахнути наприклад тому так він
знайшов це своє місце це місце було ця
роль яку він виконував так певний час
була і позитивною але очевидно що для
нього не це було найважливі тому що це
позитивно чи негативна його роль була
йому важливіше було власне формувати
свій Імідж свій образ і тому він почав
дуже цим зловживати прекрасно розуміючи
Я думаю що він прекрасно розумів е-е вже
шкідливість там на після третього тижня
своїх якихось цих заспокійливих Тез тим
не менше він це продовжував і тільки от
бачите упікшись на дуже болючій темі
пов'язаної з бомбардуванням Дніпра
тільки тоді врешті влади дійшло до
розуму що щось не так з цим конкретним
інструментом інформаційної політики
якщо вже говорити про початок війни то
після Буквально через от два-три місяці
почали почали виникати різні пісні кліпи
там Ванька станька Ну усіляки як на мене
шаруваччина
ну це норм взагалі для України це ну як
воно
в принципі чи це добре чи це норм це
інші питання це норм тому що це
нормальна реакція суспільства яке хотіло
якогось ну простої
простого це навіть не переосмисла
простої реакції на ту небезпеку які
опинилися тобто видно що хотілося б
чогось цікавішого і глибшого але для
цікавішого і глибшого треба трошки
більше часу і вже з'являється щось
цікавіше і глибше от якісь речі які Ну
мені здається залишить свій відбиток в
культурі якщо йдеться про цю
барректарщину який називають очевидно що
вона теж виконувала свою таку певну
цілющу роль для
суспільства на певний період Але мені
здається також відживається і спробує
якогось її штучного утримати в житті
доброго не дасть
можливо ж крім цього іншого треба
розуміти що дуже часто серед творців
цієї бейрексарщини Це ті люди які ну
творили і бачили себе завжди частину
якраз російської культури відповідно
навіть Після переходу їх на українську
мову Ну там все одно кокошнірчить під
цього віночка українського цього на жаль
не так легко насправді позбутися Але я
думаю що все одно певні якісь зміни
відбуваються все це все одно це вже
великий плюс що це не якась російська
попса Я не є великий прихильник е поксив
в принципі але я прекрасно розумію що
повну вартість на культура неможливо без
попси все одно хтось хтось буде слухати
тільки попсу і Хай краще це вже буде
українська попса знаю дуже багато людей
які прийшли на українську мову
дуже багато людей які раніше казали
Какая разница зараз зігнули синьо-жовтий
одного який казав Какая разница а потім
навіть сказав що без світла без газу але
без вас класно чувак добре друзі
І от питання чи зникне тренд після нашої
Перемоги на українській буде трошки
відкат того що частина людей її
повернеться до звичної російської мови
але все одно це це не
цей рух вперед Це трошки трошки
Три кроки вперед крок назад буде
звичайно от я всім розповідаю такого
ілюзію про те що Знаєте коли спирається
на якийсь високий скелі там гори 8-9
тисячники то е-е перед коли підніметься
на висоту умовних 8 500 замість того щоб
заночувати там спускається потім на
метрів 200 там зупиняється для того щоб
активуватися і тоді знову піднімається
вгору отак і рухається Україна спочатку
мир вона вперед потім трошки відкотимся
назад але вже не на вихідну точку все
одно трошки вище ніж вихідна точка потім
знову вперед а потім знову трошки кажу
так Так ми і рухаємося і в принципі це
нормально поступальний розвиток для
країни як на вашу думку цю війну назвуть
в підручниках історії
та українці Я думаю що її назвуть війною
за незалежність може навіть масштабніше
народною війною за незалежність тому що
насправді це особливості цієї війни що
мені беруть участь не тільки збройні
сили України тільки професійні солдати А
всі українці Насправді все народна і ми
ще будемо про це дискутувати Але я думаю
що приблизно така от версія і
приживеться Але я впевнений що знаю як
назвуть цю війну в Росії остання війна
російська імперії